the Joe Rogan experience I don't think
it is I don't think it's real
I think it's that's one of the things
that I love about nature you know we
were watching a video yesterday of an
owl eating the head off of a hawk cuz I
was explaining there was a sort of a
hawk war that went on in my backyard at
one point in time these owls killed
these Hawks and I would find these
headless Hawks like owls are mean
[ __ ] oh man they're so big they
look wise and kind but they are they're
badass I know they eat the Hawks heads
that's like the way they do it and I
found this out by googling who the [ __ ]
he talks heads I finally I would find
these Hawks in the middle of my my yard
with no [ __ ] hat I'm like what is
that it's great owls man they did they
were these badass owls that would by the
weight these Hawks great recommendation
from you what bunny UFC bunny I had
never seen rabbits fighting oh yeah
there's oh my god there's like I tried
to figure out which are the animals that
I want to see fight the most yeah so
giraffes are way the hell up there oh
yeah they fight wild raft battles are
the best
why do UFC is so funny it's funnier it's
like it's like kangaroo fighting for
sure well we didn't know how mean they
were to each other until my daughter's
got two male bunnies and we we left them
in a coop together I'm like oh well this
is not good and they grew up together I
mean these weren't like bunnies that
didn't know each other but they would
fight to the death and they would fight
all the time their ears were all torn
apart we had to separate them yeah so
this is it they fight all the time
they're the rodents man have you seen
penis fencing in flat worms no no I have
not penis focus okay Jamie I learned so
much from you about bizarre animal
sexual behavior all the way back to the
the cuttlefish that pretend to be women
yeah that was a good one that's a really
good one okay there's a lot of men out
there like that in society so this is
penis fencing with flatworms so this is
like in terms of why do people who like
social engineering not like biology
flatworms
have two different life cycles a male
and a female life cycle and they don't
know when they encounter each other and
romance calls whether or not they will
be male a female and it's decided by a
violent contest so they've got I believe
to plural of penis die let's go with
Pinay let's see one at any given moment
they have two penises and they attempt
to stab each other and whoever
penetrates the other succeeds in what
might be termed traumatic insemination
and the loser is assigned the feminine
gender right so the idea is that it's
more costly to bear the young than it is
to pierce the opponent so female is
given to the loser whoa
so they just do battle until someone
[ __ ] the other one right as the person
becomes a check now for that thing now
there's a worse species what bed bugs
bed bugs have no vaginal opening and so
to make one the only way that a female
can bear young is if a male attacks her
thorax and breaks it open in an act
which is definitely called traumatic
insemination so you know you have a
situation in which violent rape is the
only method by which females can leave
young so what they do to you when you
stay in a hotel is just child's play
compared to what they do my point is if
you want to talk about it Radek ating
bedbugs with DDT I'm all for it they are
the the feminists worse nightmare
species and I you know you and I talk
about the natural world look like well
that they blow up like balloons I think
so if you see one that's flat it hasn't
really gorged so they're like ticks ish
anyway the we had them under control I
believe due to DDT and but on my list of
10 nightmare species bedbugs and
flatworms for the twin traumatic
inseminations
would be way up at the top so it's like
a needle so they literally puncture
through the thorax within oh there we go
oh Christ
yeah no these these are if there is a
good lord boy this does he or she have a
lot to answer for
yeah what did you do you [ __ ] why did
you make bedbugs and why'd you make it
like that imagine what kind of natural
selection takes place where the only way
that you can reproduce is through
violent rape what's interesting there's
a different system which i think is
fascinating which is there's a conserved
quantity in dung beetles where they have
weaponry on their heads in the form of
antlers for fighting the males and it
turns out that there's an inverse
relationship so there's some resource
that's allocated between the copulatory
equipment and the weaponry that the that
the bed that the dung beetle has if they
have a lot of weapons out there goes the
Sean Connery that's good barrel thing
yeah I love it excellent I've tried it
for years I think you can't do it I
don't know if it's just a failure okay
the larger the weaponry the smaller the
copulatory upper oh so it's like a
monster truck thing yeah if you don't
have it going on you got to go get
yourself a monster truck that tiny
little gun admitted anyway so what
happens is is that the size of the
copulatory apparatus may be the engine
of speciation that when a male's
equipment no longer fits the female that
may be the cue that some dung beetles
will speciate because they can't
reproduce effectively and we don't know
why
the conserved quantity would be spread
between fighting equipment which is used
only to displace rivals and the size of
the package
[Applause]